[Musica]
buongiorno a voi
sono molto felice di essere qui quando
ero al liceo
avevo un amico che tirava di scherma
era un atleta che si allenava a quella
nazionale una cassa molto bello e la sua
mano destra era decisamente più grande
della sua mano a sinistra questo perché
da quando era bambino ogni giorno come
una goccia sulla pietra si allenava in
modo asimmetrico la mano di giovanni mi
è venuta in mente una mattina non tanto
tempo fa svegliandomi ne ho pensato
chissà in che modo la fotografia il fare
fotografia da 30 anni ha modificato il
mio corpo e soprattutto il mio modo di
pensare quando fotografo mi succede una
cosa speciale bellissima la mia mente
diventa multa e silenziosa e e si
sviluppa una sorta di ponte che mi rende
capace di cogliere la realtà della cosa
che ho di fronte che mi rende capace di
estrarne delle immagini che sono molto
specifiche che riescono a descrivere
molto bene la cosa che gli ho di fronte
ma che contemporaneamente sono anche
delle immagini che vanno a risvegliare
una parte profonda di me che vanno come
a rivelare delle verità che io molto
spesso sono in grado di capire solo dopo
perché nel mio pensiero
le mie parole arrivano un po dopo
potremmo dire che la differenza più
grande che c'è tra un discorso fatto con
le parole che non è la le parole come se
fossero delle perle di una collana e un
discorso fatto con la fotografia quello
che ci dice la fotografia proprio questo
che la fotografia è come se congelasse
l'intuizione che noi abbiamo di quella
cosa ci permette di portarci a casa
arci dopo ed è una cosa grande una
rivoluzione del pensiero in questo
giorno dedicato alla bellezza ea come
tutti noi possiamo cercare di
ristabilire il valore della bellezza e
anche usare la bellezza per risvegliare
quello a cui noi teniamo e per dargli
valore non possiamo dimenticare un libro
molto importante per noi fotografi che
si chiama proprio la bellezza in
fotografia è un libro è stato scritto da
un signore che si chiama robert adams
che ha detto molte cose ma ha detto una
cosa molto speciale che ha la forza di
un immagine lui dice che l'etimologia
persiana della parola paradiso è un
luogo decentrato e robert a dice in
fondo anche l'inquadratura non luogo
cintato potremmo dire che l'inquadratura
è il paradiso del fotografo grazie all
inquadratura infatti fotografo riesce
appunto a sottrarre un pezzo di mondo e
di spazio riesce a portarselo via
e questa sottrazione che lui fa in fondo
è quello che permette di togliere questo
pezzo da una memoria indifferenziata che
ha così ben descritto borges nel suo
meraviglioso ireneo funes una memoria
indifferenziata che senza questa
sottrazione sarebbe un deposito di
rifiuti
e proprio grazie a questa sottrazione
grazie al fatto che io posso commettere
una serie di intuizioni che io posso
pensare quindi potremmo dire proprio che
la differenza più importante della
fotografia è proprio questo costruire
un'immagine attraverso una sorta di
stratificazione di senso
il fotografo sceglie che cosa prendere
il modo in cui lo sceglie può variare
perché
dipende dal rapporto che lui ha col
tempo il rapporto che lui ha con
l'irruzione che il caso fa all'interno
della sua inquadratura sono fotografi
che è come se giocassero a tennis devono
prendere una palla al volo ci sono
fotografi che invece è come se
gettassero degli addetti e non sanno
bene che cosa tireranno su sono
fotografi che si appostano e devono
aspettare aspettare che arrivi qualche
cosa in grado di rivelargli quello che
loro stanno cercando e poi ci sono
fotografi che stanno lì ti aspettano
perché è proprio la durata il tempo come
durata che vogliono registrare ma
volendo arrivare in fondo a questa
collana di parole vorrei dirvi quello
che per me è una sintesi visiva
tanto vi un'immagine che ho rubato in
questi giorni a venezia e l'immagine
tolta da un'epigrafe che ricorda un uomo
morto alla fine di una lunga vita che i
suoi cari hanno deciso di ricordare con
una sintesi che in qualche modo riassume
con un'immagine con la potenza di un
immagine il senso della sintesi visiva
certo che tutti questi ragionamenti che
io faccio sul senso che la fotografia
per me su come la fotografia ha
modificato la mia mente sviluppando
delle parti atrofizzando le altre su
come io interagisco con la scena anche
cambiando la come qualche fisico ha ben
dimostrato come il mio stesso osservare
va a cambiare la scena fino ad arrivare
al parossismo di essere un proiettore di
realtà tutte queste cose che la
fotografia mi ha regalato in questi
trent'anni a qui devo moltissimo perché
io sono quello che sono
per queste cose che ho avuto la
possibilità di
approfondire mi lasciano comunque un
dubbio una domanda principale importante
ed è ok ma se tutto questo serve per me
a che cosa serve al mondo che io sia una
fotografa il più i e più in generale a
che cosa serve oggi nella primavera del
in un'epoca in cui la fotografia da
strumento di attenzione è diventata un
modo per non essere presente al nostro
presente in cui si fotografa prima di
guardare qui non si mostra prima di
vedere che senso ha oggi che ci siano
dei fotografi professionisti ancora un
valore oggi la fotografia per in qualche
modo inerpicarci in questo ragionamento
allora farei ancora un passo indietro e
vorrei un po spiegarvi nello specifico
in che cosa consiste il mio lavoro io
fotografo spazi lo faccio da trent'anni
e diciamo che il mio lavoro avrebbe una
grande vocazione di essere semplicemente
una riduzione perché ridurre uno spazio
all'interno di un inquadratura sembra
assolutamente una riduzione perché non
lo sia
occorre che sia un interpretazione e
perché sia un interpretazione o cose che
io abbia degli strumenti perché questa
interpretazione sia dica che io possa a
sovrapporre dei livelli di pensiero nel
momento in cui vado interpretare e
quindi molto spesso devo studiare devo
anche traguardare dei secoli che hanno
secoli in cui sono cambiati i codici di
rappresentazione dell'architettura devo
fare tutto questo farmi spiegare che
cosa implica il progetto
dell'architettura io devo tradurre
l'idea che l'architetto ha trasferito
nell'opera che io sto guardando più io
sto rappresentando
però devo riuscire a fare tutto questo
senza che tutto questo sapere tutti
questi pensieri tutte queste cose che
devo studiare vadano come un rumore
della parte sinistra del mio cervello a
impedirmi di costruire il ponte di cui
io necessità per andare a fotografare
per andare a raccontare con un'immagine
questa cosa ho bisogno che sia la luce a
comandare il mio lavoro in un qualche
modo ho bisogno di capire di lasciar
parlare la cosa che io davanti mi sono
domandata tante volte se quello che io
faccio a una via ovvero se esiste una
domanda che mi viene posta dalle cose
che io sta fotografando se esiste un
modo per fotografare che è più consono
di altri se questa scelta è più se è più
giusta
anche rispetto all'idea che ha generato
l'opera e rispetto al tempo cioè se
esiste un modo in cui le cose ci
chiedono di essere fotografate ma
torniamo alla domanda principale ormai
molto tempo fa dieci anni fa parlavo in
macchina e ascoltato ascoltando la radio
accolto come la potenza di un immagine
un frammento di una trasmissione in cui
si diceva che la società controlla gli
individui uno dei modi in cui la società
controlla gli individui a fare credere
loro che i problemi sistemici abbiano
una soluzione individuale mentre si
tratta di problemi sistemici che non
possono essere risolti individualmente
che possono essere risolti solo a
livello sistemico perché significa anche
collettivamente tutti insieme
allora ho pensato ma allora io tutto
quello che faccio per comportarmi bene
per fare bene le cose che faccio anche
eticamente intendo tutto il percorso che
io faccio per lasciare un mondo migliore
di quello che ho trovato forse non basta
non ha senso
forse io devo fare un passo in più forse
io devo cambiare il contenitore e quindi
ho pensato io voglio essere la miccia è
ovviamente dovevo farlo usando quello
che so fare facendo quello che so fare
quindi ho iniziato come prima azione a
mescolare il mio modo di lavorare con
quello del reportage quindi a non
pensare che fotografare gli spazi e
fotografare le persone siano due generi
fotografici distinti ma che possano
essere due parti di una stessa
spiegazione di uno stesso racconto ho
iniziato a lavorare con isabella balena
su gerusalemme e poi successivamente con
un foglio orsenigo con cui ho lavorato e
vissuto per vent'anni
isabella abbiamo sviluppato un
importante progetto per raccontare i
valori e disvalori del piano
paesaggistico della sardegna
il piano paesaggistico che ha valso alla
giunta soru un premio importantissimo
dell'unione europea e la testa del suo
governatore per che cosa succede succede
che se io voglio difendere un territorio
dall'aggressione di un mercato turistico
molto violento e lo faccio a suon di
leggi e decreti non funziona perché il
modello della costa smeralda entrato
così fortemente nella mente delle
persone che non è più semplicemente lo
speculatore che fa una porcheria ma è
anche il singolo che deve farsi una
casetta fa una porcheria perché il suo
modello è diventato quello lì quindi io
vado a fare un'azione culturale vado a
portare cultura come delle infiltrazioni
quando hai un braccio che ti fa male
lo faccio in maniera capillare oppure il
modello quello sbagliato vince e quindi
io pensavo che la fotografia può proprio
servire per andare a inoculare questo
questo nuovo modo di pensare ma che
bisogna trovare un modo per farlo è
un'idea nuova che bisogna capire bisogna
far girare bisogna anche confrontare con
altri per questo poi nel 2009 a seguito
del terremoto dell'aquila
abbiamo armato un grandissimo progetto
chiamando a raccolta tutti i giovani che
avevano i giovani fotografi che avevamo
formato nei corsi dell'università di
architettura di venezia e abbiamo
cercato in dieci erano circa dieci
fotografi abbiamo lavorato per un anno e
andare a colmare con l'enorme distanza
tra quello che noi vedevamo è quello che
ci veniva raccontato che era una cosa
vergognosa assurda e soprattutto per
usare il tema di questo disastro di una
città che non c'è più
per far capire alle persone che cosa
significa come dice un'amica come ha
detto nicoletta una carissima amica
aquilani cosa significa essere orfani di
una città vivere in un luogo che ha
perso il suo centro storico suo
municipio la su tutti i suoi luoghi
dalle biblioteche non avere più nessun
luogo identificativo a livello
collettivo e quindi abbiamo fatto poi
questa mostra molto importante che è
andata prima di tutto a venezia a
palazzo ducale e poi ha girato in altri
luoghi facendo in modo che nessuno di
noi firma sulle sue fotografie perché
era un omaggio all'aquila ma abbiamo
discusso insieme moltissimo su come
costruire questo progetto
diciamo che abbiamo fatto un gruppo di
lavoro tutto insieme
abbiamo prodotto questo lavoro l'ultimo
atto ormai di quattro anni fa un lavoro
che è nato insieme da un'idea condivisa
con roberto sartori e antonio di cecco
lavorare ancora a l'aquila portare
all'aquila 50 fotografi e farli lavorare
fianco a fianco
ognuno con un cittadino questo perché se
io ritengo che la fotografia di
paesaggio sia destinata non
all'americano che deve mandare le
cartoline ma a risvegliare il valore del
bene comune negli abitanti di quel luogo
è chiaro che l'unica possibilità che ho
è mettere insieme lo sguardo esperto
allenato di un fotografo con lo sguardo
ravvicinato di un cittadino in modo che
possano nutrirsi a vicenda e stata
un'esperienza veramente speciale abbiamo
lavorato insieme per una settimana i
fotografi hanno discusso tra lavoro di
metodo di contenuti
i cittadini hanno nutrito tantissimo
questo processo e penso che ne siano
stati nutriti ma è un progetto troppo
grande per un gruppo di fotografi di
belle speranze noi siamo molto battuti
ma non siamo riusciti a coinvolgere le
istituzioni quelle stesse istituzioni
che si riempiono la bocca della parola
partecipazione e non pensano che la
cultura sia fondamentale che sia
necessario riportare la cultura e che si
sa che la fotografia come cultura visiva
sia uno strumento necessario per andare
a riparlare di partecipazione e di
paesaggio e questa la grande scommessa
che la fotografia possa tornare essere
utile e che un fotografo possa lavorare
per qualcosa di più che una mostra in
una galleria che possa farci vedere
qualcosa di più del suo ombelico quando
fotografa il paesaggio che tutti insieme
possiamo pensare che la cultura anche
quella visiva
sia un nutrimento che c'è fondamentale è
che questo per chiudere ancora con un
pensiero di robert adams che la
fotografia possa riacquistare il suo
valore riconciliatorio ci permetta di
riconciliarci con questi luoghi
sfigurati di questo paesaggio
meraviglioso in cui viviamo e possa
permetterci di dire tutti insieme
sono felice di essere qui grazie
[Musica]